>> Bret: CONGRESSMAN, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> THANKS.
>> Bret: FOLLOWING ALL THE
DEVELOPMENTS.
MEANWHILE, TENSIONS EXTREMELY
HIGH BETWEEN TWO NUCLEAR POWERS.
NOT HERE AND THE U.S., WORLD
LEADERS URGING PAKISTAN AND
INDIA TO TAKE SOME DEEP BREATHS
AFTER TWO DAYS
TRADE YANKS HAS A ROUND UP FROM
OUR MIDDLE EAST NEWSROOM.
>> THE PAKISTANI MILITARY
SHUTDOWN TO INDIAN JETS AS A
COUNTRY'S CLASS IN THE REMOTE
KASHMIR REGION.
IN THE AREA OF THE TWO NUCLEAR
POWERS HAVE FOUGHT OVER FOR
DECADES.
AN INDIAN PILOT IN PAKISTANI
CUSTODY AFTER BEING CAPTURED AND
BEATEN BY LOCAL FORCES.
AIR BASES IN PAKISTAN ARE AT WAR
ALERT LEVELS WHILE INDIAN
PRIME MINISTER NARENDRA MODI
GAVE HIS MILITARY A FREE HAND.
COMES ONE DAY AFTER INDIAN JETS
BOMBED TARGETS IN PAKISTAN THAT
OFFICIALS SAY BELONG TO THE
TERRORIST GROUP
THEY KILLED 42 INDIAN SOLDIERS
IN A CAR BOMB ATTACK EARLIER
THIS MONTH.
>> INDIA HAD INFORMED ABOUT THE
ACCIDENT TOOK YESTERDAY.
AGAINST A TERRORIST TRAINING
CAMP IN PAKISTAN.
BASED ON CRITICAL EVIDENCE THAT
THEY INTENDED TO LAUNCH MORE
ATTACKS.
>> INDIA'S SPOKESMAN WOULD ONL
>> INDIA'S SPOKESMAN WOULD ONY
SAY THAT ONE JET WAS SHOT DOWN
WHILE CONFIRMING REPORTS THAT A
PAKISTANI JET WAS TARGETED BY
INDIA.
PAKISTAN BRIEFLY CLOSED ITS
AIRSPACE AS THE TWO COUNTRIES
TRY TO AVOID A MAJOR CONFLICT.
>> I WANT TO ASK A QUESTION FROM
THE INDIAN GOVERNMENT
CONSIDERING THE NATURE IS THAT
BOTH OF US HAVE.
CAN WE AFFORD ANDY
MS. CALCULATIONS.
IF THE SITUATION ESCALATES,
WHERE WILL IT GO.
>> FROM THE UNITED KINGDOM TO
CHINA TO THE EUROPEAN UNION,
LEADERS URGING COMMON DIALOGUE
AS BOTH COUNTRIES POSSESS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT THE